[Music]
[Music]
homie look what I become
[Music]
listen uh episode 198 we're two away
from 200 if you're listening to this
uh one thing about our podcast man I got
to tell you guys one day we're talking
business one day we're talking politics
one day we're talking economy one day
we're talking interest rates one day
it's like and today we're talking
Epstein and an author who Whitney Webb
wrote two books called One Nation Under
blackmail she did so much investigative
journalism on this topic that she had to
do a volume one and a volume two the
first one is between the intelligence
and crime that gave rise to Jeffrey
Epstein and the second one is around how
organized crime gave rise to Jeffrey
Epstein this goes back to Mossad we're
going to talk about Jelena Maxwell's
Father Robert Maxwell who is a very very
interesting character himself I think he
came from a family of nine and I think
he had nine kids or seven kids and I
think the last kid he had was Jolene so
we got a lot of things to be taught
talking about uh her background again
outside of that as an investigative
journalist she does uh she's an American
writer a researcher covering
intelligence Tech surveillance and civil
liberties for the podcast unlimited
hangout uh Whitney's also a staff writer
for mint Press News and contributor to
Ben Swan's uh website truth in media
having said that Whitney thank you so
much for being a guest here hey thanks
for having me it's good to have you on
yeah I'm really happy to be here if I
could just uh correct the bio really
quick though um I used to work ferment
press I still contribute there and I I
write for my own site now got it so you
used to work that you contr you just
contribute you don't work there anymore
yeah okay I mean that's important to say
yeah so the audience knows the people
though I you know I like the team at
mint Press News at all don't but you
don't want him to tweet out today St
Patrick by David said Whitney is still a
writer with us I feel like the intention
of his entire episode today is setting
the record straight
on a multiple level of topics yeah well
I'm worse but the whole thing is like um
some of the stuff we're going to talk
about today guys I mean if you just
brace for impact it's going to be weird
it's going to be deep it's going to be
if you're already into this and you've
already been following it for yourself
you're gonna say okay I know a lot about
this and I've been looking forward to
this podcast great if you don't you
don't follow this you're driving in your
car maybe if you used to going 85 go 72
you know if you're you know at work and
you got your employees around you and
you got like a deadline today maybe
don't listen to this at a 2.0 speed
listen to this at 1.25 slow down a
little bit because we're going to talk
about a lot of different things so just
an opening thing there's a lot of things
a person can do investigative journalism
on you you can do stuff on JFK
assassination you can do stuff on many
different things what got you turned on
about wanting to learn about what's
going on with Epstein well it was
actually
um when Alex Acosta who is Secretary of
Labor under Trump he he was quoted by
Vicki Ward and some other people are
saying that the reason he backed off on
Epstein was because Epstein he was told
that Epstein quote belonged to
intelligence so I originally wasn't
planning to write about the case because
I tend to
um focus more on under-reported stories
and there was a lot of Buzz around
Epstein after his arrest at that time
and but once the intelligence angle came
up it was kind of like well I'd like to
see you know where that leads because
even when that acknowledgment came out
there wasn't a lot of interest at least
it seemed to me anyway in mainstream
media
um and getting really to the bottom of
what that means that he belonged to
intelligence what does that mean belongs
to intelligence it could mean a lot of
things right it could he had he could
either have been an intelligence asset
he could have been you know an agent and
also you know which intelligence agency
are we talking about right so it was
kind of an interesting an open question
but you know once you get that type of
acknowledgment about someone as
controversial as Epstein you know a lot
of things start to move to sort of
protect the people who would have been
his Handler when did you first hear his
name and when did the general population
out there start hearing his name because
I don't think I heard his name until
2018-19 is that am I yeah my number's
right where did you hear 2019 was the
arrest and I'd heard of him you know
before because he was arrested you know
previously in around what 2006 2007. so
his name was around because you know
even then people knew of the association
with people like Bill Clinton and Trump
and a lot of you know very powerful and
influential people he's been talked
about for a while yeah it's not a new
thing but as far as it's a lot more
extensive yeah of course absolutely the
average person hearing Epstein's name is
in the last handful of years so
absolutely that's that's a good uh
question right there so so maybe from
this perspective what does the average
person in your eyes since you've been
doing a lot of due diligence and
research on this what does the average
person think they know about Epstein and
maybe we can get into what are some
things we don't know that we should
definitely know
all right so as far uh as I see it uh
the narrative
um about Jeffrey Epstein that I think
most people have absorbed because it's
been the mainstream media coverage they
focus pretty specifically on what he was
doing from 2000 to about 2006 or so and
only on the sex crimes
and beyond that it you know maybe
um a handful of outlets have talked
about things maybe in the 90s maybe
things after his first arrest what he
did between that time and his second
arrest but really beyond that it's a
very narrow focus in my opinion because
this is a guy that really entered you
know the workforce I guess you could say
sometime in the 70s and he was you know
visiting the Clinton White House in the
90s and there's been very little
interest
um especially an American mainstream
media and talking about that particular
period of time and Jeffrey Epstein's
career
um actually like the UK media Outlets
like the Daily Mail and and Outlets like
that have been much more focused on
those aspects of the Epstein case than
American mainstream media and that's
pretty telling because you know Bill
Clinton's an American former American
president not a former British prime
minister so you know why the lack of
focus The Daily Beast has also talked a
little bit about that but as far as I
know that's you know pretty much it so
let's so let's get into it so for for
for again like you said a lot of people
they know about you know what happened
some of the sex scandals and in the
earlier years great we know about that
we've seen that but going all the way
back to how he got started in the 70s
the influence he had there's got to be
people that either trained him to do
what he did in the 90s 2000 or
influenced them negatively and taught
him some bad habits a lot of times in
business we'll bring an agent that comes
from another company that company if
they do forgeries because that guy
learned some of those habits at a
different company before they brought it
you know how did you learn how to do
this well when I used to do mortgage it
was called creative financing oh my God
we don't do that that's not the right
way of doing business so how do you
yourself when you look at somebody like
this someone must have taught them these
bad habits right so it looks to me that
it was somewhere around the time uh he
went to Bear Stearns which was his first
uh really entry into the financial world
because you know as I just mentioned
earlier most people think if I've seen
as a sex criminal based on my research
he stressed as much a financial criminal
as a sex criminal
um but in the book I try and go even
further back to that in pursuit of you
know where this intelligence tie may
have originally started and it you know
he was apparently had a British royal
family connection as as early as the
early 70s like 1971 when he was the only
in his 20s
um you know he was supposed to be
backpacking in Europe there's some weird
Mystique around that particular trip
that I know in in the book
um but after that he you know went to
the Dalton school which I think some
people that looked into the case you
know after his his second arrest are
probably familiar with because the the
man that hired him there uh who is the
the Headmaster of Dalton at the time was
William Barr's father Donald Barr and
the philbar as in the yeah the two-time
Attorney General yes and his father was
a former uh a veteran of the office of
strategic Services which is a precursor
to the CIA and then he went to Columbia
and was sort of a talent scout I guess
in a sense uh because he he ran a lot of
um programs at Columbia focusing on
talented high schoolers and uh it's very
possible that Epstein was a very gifted
high schooler in the New York area he
graduated high school very young he went
to the Interlochen Academy of Arts
um and was a very talented uh teenager
so it's very possible he may have met
Donald Barr that way
but Donald barf for whatever reason
hires him to go to the Dalton school and
according to you know former students
quoted by the New York Times he showed a
weird interest in partying uh with
underage kids even then and wanted to
drink and some claim they hit on him and
all this stuff and other people said
that was normal at the Dalton school
um and all of that and the reason for
him leaving isn't quite clear but he was
sort of headhunted there by Alan
Greenberg of bear Stearns and went um
and and joined that particular bank and
Alan Greenberg just a couple years after
he brought Epstein into bear Stearns
became the head of bear Stearns
um so Epstein was sort of from what I
understand seeing his mentor was
basically Greenberg and Greenberg goes
to the top of the bank and so obviously
that helps Epstein's career
um he you know climbs the ladder pretty
rapidly rapidly there and then starts
working um first with some of their
Elite clientele the identities of which
we don't exactly know but based on the
circumstances under which he left it was
related to an SEC investigation uh
focusing on insider trading of the
bronfman family comp company Seagrams I
believe yeah so it seems like Edgar
bronfman he may have been involved in
advising him on some things and what he
was apparently well known for and
talented in at Bear Stearns was amazing
people about tax law so there may have
been some sort of tax evasion stuff or
something I mean he left under rather
murky circumstances and there's a lot of
you know differing opinions coming out
of there but in looking at the
particular Seagram's insider trading
stuff and that the SEC was tipped off
that Epstein knew something about it in
Epstein leaves so there's no blowback
for the bank because at this point right
his
um his mentors the head of of the bank
that could obviously have impacts all
the way up that bear Stearns right and
another thing that's interesting is just
a couple uh around that same time uh the
who the person who had been the legal
counsel for Bear Stearns most of the
time that Epstein was working for that
bank became CIA director under Reagan
Bill Casey
so these links by the way if you go on
Donald Barr because we went through that
very quickly Bill Barr's father Donald
Barr okay so that's Donald Barr when
when he was uh uh at Dalton to just to
kind of put perspective putting put into
perspective for the audience how big of
a deal is the school uh Dalton
well from what I understand it's kind of
one of the you know I'm not from New
York City and I've never been there so
you know I don't have like an Insider
understanding necessarily of that but
from what I understand a lot of you know
Elite wealthy people went to the school
send their children there yeah and and
when when he hired uh uh Epstein to
become a professor teaching mathematics
this is a guy that's never had a degree
before right like Epstein never got it
he would have not been eligible as I
understand it to even teach in public
school in New York how does that make
any sense for him to get a job even
though he's never had anything before
right so Donald Barr apparently hired
unconventional teachers and was known
for this right but he actually left by
the time Epstein started hiring
decisions were apparently made in the
spring in that summer Donald Barr left
after having made those hiring decisions
so during most of epson's time there it
was another Headmaster and from what I
understand Donald Barr's um him leaving
the Dalton school was rather acrimonious
like he was sort of forced out it seems
by uh Angry parents and some angry
teachers yeah so apparently he was uh he
was there till what summer of 94 is when
I'm when you're forcing me to do so much
research is not even funny I think it's
like 74. 74 yeah that's the summer of 74
and then Epstein started working months
prior to that right like in 73 teaching
physics teaching physics and you you
don't have a four-year degree that
that's that's that's incredibly weird to
me you know it's weird that he was hired
considering that he couldn't even have
taught at public school is this Epstein
or Bill Barr's father we're talking
about it so so um well who is teaching
no no Donald
Epstein got it but Epstein didn't have a
four-year degree to teach anything but
even yeah he didn't graduate from
undergraduate yeah so so just think
about and then by the way the one thing
that's also pretty weird with this whole
connection is Donald Barr wrote a book
uh space relations yes space relations a
public publish a science fiction novel
that contained several prominent
references to and descriptions of rape
and sexual slavery exact slavery that's
true and that was published shortly
after he left the Dalton school so
there's a weird mix here right but I
mean you can't make any direct
connection necessarily but given
everything else we're talking about
about Epstein intelligence the sex
crimes all of that it starts to look
kind of you know weird you know this far
back but you know obviously over time it
gets can you can you do me a favor and
just pull up the following pull up the
text I just sent you and the only reason
I'm showing this is because I know the
folks at YouTube value Snopes because
they want things to be uh uh uh looked
at and you know how if you can pull that
up but while you're doing that the the
strange part of the story is the fact
that the person that ends up putting
Epstein in jail is Donald Barr's son
William Barr well at this exact time
when Donald Barr is hires Jeffrey
Epstein and all of this is going on at
the Dalton School William Barr is
already at the CIA William Barr is
already at the CIA that's where he
started his career pretty much in 73-74
I think it was after well so Epstein I
think it started in 74. so as I
mentioned earlier Donald Barr made
hiring decisions in the spring leaves
that summer and then Epstein starts that
fall semester and in the same period of
time William Barr's already associated
with the CIA so for the folks at YouTube
and others here's Snopes okay so we
we're fact checking this did Bill Barr's
father Mentor Jeffrey Epstein and write
a bizarre novel okay so if I can comment
on that yeah we're not talking I didn't
say anything right now we haven't said
anything about there being a mentor
really sure it was a hiring decision
right so a lot of times with these fact
check sites they'll put in like oh there
was no Mentor relationship and then they
debunked the whole thing but Donald Barr
did write a bizarre novel yeah and he
did hire Jeffrey Epstein can you pull up
a little bit hang on hang on but let's
see what these guys are saying because
these guys people follow these guys
mostly fall so go up go up go up go up
go up go up so okay down at the top let
me read that one first uh claim Donald
Barr father of U.S general Bill Barr
higher Jeffrey Epstein as a teacher
served as his mentor and wrote a novel
about men raping teenage girls okay go
to the bottom mostly false what's true
Donald Barr was Headmaster of Dalton
School in New York until the summer of
74 and 74 Epstein began working as a
math and physics professor at the school
in 1973 Barr published a science fiction
novel that contained several prominent
references to and the scriptures rape
and sexual slavery what's false is
Dalton is not an uh all-girl school and
was not so when Epstein worked there to
claim that bar was Epstein's Mentor
appears to be more than an idol uh
speculations unsupported by evidence
bars and novel does not celebrate
slavery or sexual violence uh against
underage girls and in one instance the
protagonist brutal murders another
character to avenge the rape of a
teenage girl
right so I wasn't familiar with the date
of the the publication of the book but I
knew it was around the the ballpark you
know the same time that he's um you know
hiring Epstein so I didn't know it was
it was earlier but I've never heard the
claim that it was an all-girl school as
far as I understand it was it's just at
this time I mean who would want to write
a book like this genders but I mean I so
I haven't read the book I've only read
parts of it but from what I understand
there is like a sex slavery thing but
not necessarily for like minors right
but it is an odd book to be sure Whitney
I know we're gonna go a bunch of
different directions but what I want to
sort of hunker down on is what's the
importance of this narrative that we're
creating right now or not that we're
creating that we're discussing with Bill
Barr's father Donald Barr Epstein what's
the importance
I would say this is the beginning of
several other examples in Epstein's
career where it seems like he has a
meteoric rise that would otherwise have
been unavailable to him if it weren't
for some sort of connections that he
possessed you know he's stepping into
some sort of support network that
protects him not just through his uh you
know Financial criminality but his sex
criminality because remember he was
doing this for a long time including the
sex crimes and nothing happened to him I
mean you have someone like in January
2020 of Cindy McCain John McCain's wife
coming out and say we all knew what
Epstein was doing
I mean and there's no direct John McCain
McCain Epstein connection that I've seen
so this means you know in the U.S Senate
it's known
what he's doing and nothing happens to
him you don't operate like that and
abuse thousands of girls and get away
with all of this stuff if you don't have
someone behind you right so this is just
a case example sort of an initial case
example of like this sort of meteoric
ride social climbing how does this
happen yeah there's something behind the
scenes here and this is sort of the
first he wasn't even qualified to teach
public school right so he's teaching at
one of the most elite you know schools
in New York and it's kind of awesome
this is at age 20. I did the math this
was in 1973 he was born in 1953 give or
take so he's College age give or take at
this point yeah I believe so
but he didn't graduate from college
right so it's just unusual that he'd be
in that circumstance at this elite
school and then it's again unusual that
uh the head you know one of the top guys
at Bear Stearns would be like come work
for my bank a guy that hasn't graduated
from college and all this stuff and it's
supposedly because he mentored his
daughter or his son I think I mean
there's a lot of discrepancies because
the daughter was like no nothing to do
with me and then other people were like
yes and you know no one wants to say
they had any association with him it's a
very basic question because we can go
you know laundry list of the nasty crazy
things he's done but very simply
was he a very smart guy like as far as
like anyone around him was like oh he's
really smart that guy knows what he's
doing yeah he's just basic IQ and basic
you know education well you've had a mix
of responses right in the since since he
became Infamous of people being like
yeah he was really smart and then other
people being like no he was just a
schmoozer and charismatic and that was
it and he just Bamboozled people and I
think the latter is sort of um people
trying to go back and rewrite history to
an extent I think he was very good at I
mean obviously he graduated from high
school really young but I think uh he
his real you know knack for Stuff had to
do with his you know Financial abilities
let me just put it to this way you're
not going to get away for this long if
you're not smart or even there's a
better word for it
not cunning it's conniving you know uh
uh you know where you can get away with
you know manipulating people for this
long yeah yeah there's Brilliance there
he had a skill set that made people a
lot of money a lot of money and that's
part of why he got away with this for so
long so let's the skill set you're
talking about is sex blackmail is that
is that what you're talking about I
think that's part of it but as far as as
it comes to to Jeffrey Epstein it looks
like that sex blackmail angle didn't
really start until the early 90s and
this is a person we're talking about
Epstein in the 70s right now then
there's the whole question mark of the
1980s and Jeffrey Epstein and I would
say that um like I mentioned earlier the
financial crime angle is just as
important as the sex crime mango with
Epstein and it's also the least explored
when you're talking about this guy so
what what do we not know what do we not
know about the 80s okay so he leaves
bear Stearns I sort of mentioned there
was this insider trading investigation
all of that and then Epstein goes on to
claim that he's a financial Bounty
Hunter that's his term for it and
there's numerous quotes and mainstream
media of people that knew Epstein that
were told during this period that he was
a person who claimed to find or hide
money for powerful people
so he's either finding money that was
looted or he's helping people hide
looted money so right there you know
that he's involved in some sort of
Financial gray area and that he has a
very good working knowledge of the
Offshore Banking system
I mean that we can deduce from that
right I think that's pretty so how does
that how does that help him so it's a
financial Bounty okay I get that but the
Bounty people I know they're he kills
himself a bounty hunter a financial
Bounty Hunter that's he's used that
terminology before you're saying yeah
yeah this isn't mainstream media yeah a
financial Bounty Hunter there's only a
handful of ways you're able to get that
but either way whether you're helping
people find money that was stolen or
helping people hide their stolen money
you know where that money goes and this
you know the the lambranth of where that
money is hidden you know it better than
anyone and that's why people go to you
so so so the blackmail part is the
creative one so uh in the insurance
industry there's something called
premium financing and premium financing
cases pay a lot of commissions we're
talking five you know 10 million dollars
of commissions one guy is doing a
premium financing case with a big
billionaire guy and I'm not going to
tell the story of who's who but he takes
the client away from the competitor so
the competitor who was about to close
this case is going to get paid five
something million dollars is upset and
says you got to give this client to me
because it's mine the other guy's like
I'm not going to take the client I'm not
going to give the client he says no
problem he has three people that work
for him all drop dead gorgeous girls
they go and investigate because a lot of
times these successful people they eat
at the same place they sit at the same
place so it's easy to find them he goes
creates an environment where the girl
it's the same script she's going through
a husband beating all this stuff and she
she says I'm so sorry sits at the same
place at the bar eventually invites him
back to his room her room they go
upstairs they do what they do he leaves
the videotapes the the insurance guy
sends to the other guy says if you don't
give me that client back this is going
to your wife to your clients to your
employees to everybody so this is
something as weird as it sounds this is
not a abnormal thing this goes on
in these circles specifically so no
knowing what you know when you call
yourself a financial Bounty Hunter have
you been able to investigate and see
what his methods were to get the money
back unfortunately it's super murky
there's very little we do know but from
we do know it is pretty interesting so
it seems like um Epstein during this
period had some sort of relationship
with a banknote as a bank of credit and
commerce International BCCI uh according
to the BCCI report which is the U.S
Senate report BCCI was involved in sex
trafficking of minors
apparently for VIPs and other people
whatever that means I don't know but
some of them were pre-pubescent and this
is coming straight from the Senate
report right very underexplored aspect
of this case if the more you look at
BCCI it seems like you know it was
nominally a bank a Development Bank but
really it's um
um to me sort of more like a price was a
private intelligence apparatus sort of
masquerading as a bank a lot of
intelligence involvement from the
beginning apparently Pakistani
intelligence but there was also you know
reports in Newsweek going decades back
of course because BCCI imploded in 1991
saying that the CIA had some sort of
role in in creating BCCI and was very
involved in money laundering and all
other sorts of stuff this particular
bank and Stephen hoffenberg who was a
mentor to Jeffrey Epstein at some point
later in the 1980s has said that Jeffrey
Epstein had a relationship with this
bank and we know from people like um
Vicki Ward for example that during this
you know Financial Bounty Hunter phase
one of Epstein's main clients was admin
khashoggi the Arms Dealer who had a
relationship with many intelligence
agent khashoggi as in Jamal khashoggi
the journal they're related wow yeah
crazy how this web yeah I mean these at
least very nuts yeah
um but I don't know if I necessarily you
know am qualified to talk about the
Jamal khashoggi case uh but yeah but
just these names that keep popping up
yeah Bill Barr what does he have to do
with this journalist Clinton Trump this
well the intelligence thing being
confirmed from someone like Alex Acosta
he was told Epstein belonged to
intelligence and you're talking about
all these names they have all these
different intelligence affiliations it
starts to become clear there's something
much deeper to the Epstein case that you
know mainstream media isn't interested
in Touching at all
um but anyway Edna khashoggi during this
period in the 1980s one of his main
Banks was also BCCI and this is the same
time when Edna khashoggi starts to put a
lot of this um
stuff that later becomes known as Iran
Contra into motion which also involves
of course some drug trafficking money
laundering arms trafficking you know
it's a very complex uh which Pat is very
familiar with with the Iran Contra
affair so so okay so let's let's keep
going back to the 80s so is that pretty
much all we know about what happened
with them in the 80s with the financial
Bounty Hunter stuff well the other thing
is too right so you know Bill Casey had
this relationship with bear Stearns he's
CIA director Epstein leaves and then he
teams up with someone like Adnan
khashoggi and then at the around the
same time other two other people take on
Adam ashoki as clients Robert Keith Gray
who worked on very closely with Bill
Casey on the Reagan campaign and Roy
Cohn the lawyer who also worked very
closely
um with Bill Casey on the Reagan
campaign and both and as I note in
volume one of my book both of those men
have very extensive ties to sexual
blackmail Roy Cohen does yeah oh yeah
was a lawyer for a lot of mobsters for
many of them yes and many powerful
people in New York he was the guy you
got when you know you needed somebody to
take care of you now the the royco is
Roy Cohen's story at all linked to Jay
Edgar Hoover or no is there any
connection between yeah I mean I I write
about it pretty extensively they were
very close and you know even Roy cohn's
uh probably one of his best known
biographers Nicholas von Hoffman that
wrote citizen cone uh just couldn't it
really even explain why the official
story of J Edgar Hoover and Roy cohn's
meeting uh he just found it very odd
because it it's so it was so uncommon at
that time for someone to just Waltz in
to Jay Jay Edgar Hoover's office and
have that kind of access to him uh right
away but there's been several
um
um authors and well I document this all
in volume one pretty extensively uh that
that point to there having been some
sort of relationship previously that
they had met previously through through
some sort of um weird sexual it seems to
have been a sexual blackmail operation
and Roy Cohn later apparently admitted
this to an NYPD uh detective there was
some sort of sexual blackmail thing
going on that entrapped J Edgar Hoover
and Roy Cohn participated not
necessarily in entrapping J Edgar Hoover
but they had these sex parties right and
so J Edgar Hoover was seen at these Roy
Cohn was seen as these in a guy that was
close to both Hoover and Cohn Louis
Rosensteel who was a liquor Baron of
that particular area was also sort of in
the same same circuit and it it's
alleged that this all took place at the
Plaza Hotel it's important to say this
Roku while you're going through this
everything that you write about is
primary sources right it's not for the
most part you're going through primary
sources or you know so in the case of
this a lot of it comes from uh books
different books written by people that
are sourced that way from interviews and
things like that
um but yeah I mean I I anyone that looks
in the book and goes through the
footnotes of what I write about is going
to find like very high quality sourcing
sure so
so you're not saying Roy Cohen was
involved in the sexual blackmail against
Jay Edgar Hoover is why you know the mob
was able to say so Roy wasn't involved
at all to Corner Jay Edgar Hoover so he
can help them out that was not actually
not necessarily but they seemed to have
been in this they attended these same
sex parties that the mob was apparently
using to Blackmail people and when Roy
Cohn admitted his involved he uh
apparently admitted to this NYPD by
Squad detective
um that he was involved in these kind of
operations but that he only did it
because he had been entrapped originally
so this uh NYPD detective had like a he
when I interviewed him he expressed us
like some sympathy towards come like he
felt bad for him but Khan did this stuff
because he was apparently entrapped at
some point and you know you have to keep
in mind this is a period of time when
it's very difficult to be a gay man in
DC
so you know a lot of this stuff is sort
of like underground and you know it if
it were to come out that they were
homosexual it could have ended their
political careers both of them him and
Jade groups why the blackmail was so
effective right absolutely and by the
way even Roy Cohen's assistant who was
with him they call him he was his lover
he died in 1984 from AIDS that's Roy
Cohen's assistant who died in 1984 from
AIDS and that's the AIDS pandemic where
you know everybody was talking about
raccoon also died for me you're right I
know but it you know the point being is
his assistant died from it and then boom
the same thing happened the stories with
J Edgar Hoover he was the director of
the CIA FBI I'm sorry FBI but the
stories about cross-dressing and high
heels how how much truth is is in that
okay so uh there's a there's a couple
different sources from that so one is
Susan Rosensteel or I think that's her
name if I'm not mistaken it's Louis
rosensteel's fourth wife as a source for
that and then um there was a separate
sort there there were two or three
separate sources on related to Susan
Rosensteel that corroborated that claim
so when there's that many sources it's
almost like when there's smoke there's
fire how much well you know it's um
when it's corroborated I mean I I feel
like then it's possible to report it I
mean people can make their own
conclusions I mean there's some people I
think that have a very vested image and
the the image of Hoover that we're all
old so like you know there'll be people
it doesn't matter how much you
corroborated there'll be people who
won't do you believe that Pat no what
about J Edgar Hoover and cross-dressing
and if I'm going to put odds nothing is
100 because I wasn't there to witness it
while he was getting it on but I would
say 90 oh it's that high I think so I
think I don't think it's I don't think
it's a issue anymore his secret life
with like Clyde Tolson and you know that
he had a he was a homosexual and all of
this is well known and there's even been
like Bill Clinton's speeches from the
90s where he sort of references that
about J Edgar Hoover and everyone laughs
in the room right so like you know there
may be some stuff that isn't known
necessarily to the American public but
like in these Elite circles and be seen
you know they stuff gets out right my
question about Elite circles we
constantly hear this word elite the
elites the rich Elites the global Elites
the elites you know these days in
America everything's so fracturized I'm
on team red I'm a Democrat very popular
very polarized right and one thing I
always say is like I don't care about
the blue I don't care about the red I
follow the green right it's all about
the money follow the money right oh
right there yeah these themes that we're
talking about with J Edgar Hoover back
in the 50s and beyond that JFK and to
the 80s and Reagan and Clinton in the
90s up until today and Trump there seems
to be like three common themes money
power and sex and that just sort of
pierces through everything is that fair
to say yeah I'd agree with that those
are major the major three things
probably that are a Common Thread
throughout my book because my book
really starts back in like the 40s and
goes up and so yeah I mean through that
those decades that's
that's what makes the world go around as
far as the U.S is concerned in power
because you know a lot of people look at
the politicians and think that's the
power right but who is backing those
politicians and who's backing those
backers and to paraphrase J uh Jr or
Tolkien uh who's the banker of those
backers right so there's like always
these different layers of power and
talking about someone like Roy Cohn Roy
Cohn had a system called the favor bank
system
which is what he called it and everyone
he interacted with had an open account
in his Faber bank and you either you
know do deals with him or you go against
him and you get Plus or minuses and you
know you make all these unsavory
alliances especially New York City to
stay in power
um and things like that and Roy conlord
a lot of this just growing up as a very
young boy he was not typical he was very
interested in power in accumulating it
for a very young age
um and he was very close to like very
prominent mob leaked businessmen like
generoso Pope his uh who was uh the
father of one of his best friends
growing up and had this uh he he was
very close to Frank Costello the mobster
and ran one of the biggest cement
companies or concrete companies in New
York obviously very important to real
estate and very close to organized crime
very politically powerful because he ran
uh had a I think a monopoly on the
Italian language newspapers in New York
for Italian immigrants so he basically
controlled that voting block to a
significant degree
and so you know Roy Cohen had sort of an
inside track into how all these deals
are made behind closed doors with
businessmen and politicians his father
was a very prominent judge with a
Democratic party and at this point you
know the Democratic party in New York a
lot of that power basis unions and Ma
the mob took over a lot of the unions
very early on in the in the 20s and the
30s and there are even some cases I know
in the book where you know they wanted a
mob backed politician in power they
threatened the life of some guy and then
they just put the mob guy in and this is
back in the 30s so if things really
changed I don't necessarily think that
it has I think more mainstream media
willingness to look at those cases has
declined steadily uh with the years
because what kind of journalist wants to
take those kind of risks right
especially if you live in the swamp that
you're writing about Pat let me get your
opinion because this this is
mind-blowing to me I don't know if
there's anybody on the planet
Like Pat that has interviewed
collectively business people political
figures and MOB people like if you put
those three Trifecta together
Pat is I don't I mean venture to say I
don't know if anybody's on your level in
that regard the these you've interviewed
Rudy Giuliani and and kind of how they
compare you know what the mob does and
political figures like when you're
processing all this she brought up Frank
Costello uh like when you're hearing
these common themes like how are you
processing all this no I mean listen
it's it's it's a I I can see this
happening because every the easiest way
to get somebody like have to you ever
see somebody that flips like even the
conversation came up with Joe mentioned
we're talking about why did he all of a
sudden go from not supporting to
supporting what happened there what
happened with uh Colonel Powell go from
you know where he was at to all of a
sudden flipping why do some people all
of a sudden dramatically flip which
makes no sense you were loyal 60 years
to this cause then dramatically you go
XYZ did somebody have something on you
is somebody calling and saying take a
look at this picture take a look at this
video take a look at this I'm not
telling you to do this all I'm saying to
you is if you don't there are people
much more powerful than me that are
going to probably leak this to the
public and I don't want your reputation
to be ruined in the face of your kids
and all that other stuff there are very
few people that are willing to say go
ahead do it I don't care go ahead do
very very few people matter of fact I
wanted to say it's point zero zero zero
one percent because these same people
that are driven by power sex and money
are also driven by Legacy and their
reputation and so the moment you risk
their legacy and reputation that's the
ultimate control but what what do you
want to talk about the ultimate slave
the ultimate slave is when somebody has
that kind of dirt on you for the rest of
your life you have to do whatever they
tell you to do at the sacrifice of
anything so it has that happened was the
mob involved for doing this the mob
wants to control and have power over you
back in the days the way they did it
they had many creative ways of doing it
I don't see this not being the case but
let's go back into the 40s because
there's a lot of names when we go back
to the 40s
so my interest in the following is this
here's what my interest is
anybody that becomes a a high high level
criminal uh in any industry
saw it through somebody else typically
someone taught them how to do this yeah
it's not like they accidentally picked
this up somebody sought them how to do
it taught them how to do this
you know a few that maybe they're
inspired by a book they wrote a book
they read or movie they watched but for
the most part they saw someone do it so
Epstein goes back Dalton brings him in
who who taught him the sex black male
model though you don't know that right
no it's very hard to know you know I
mean I'm sure there's some people who
claim they know but you know frankly
from what I've seen it's it's very hard
to know but I think it's more likely it
took place somewhere in the 1980s it was
probably either BCCI or even someone
like Adnan khashoggi right Edna
khashoggi had a yacht and he would he
basically he was accused of having a
harem of women on that yacht and he
would use that to butter up
politicians private businessmen whoever
he needed to you know
help him accomplish his goals which you
know more often than I was you know
selling weapons weapons deals right so
um you know there's a lot of different
places that could have come from like I
mentioned earlier BCCI was sex
trafficking on basically an industrial
scale and as I note in the book the way
it's described what they were doing in
the BCCI report very similar to what
Jeffrey Epstein and Elaine Maxwell later
did there was a woman he was working
with in that BCCI report on so this is
the the creator of um of BCCI and a
woman in in Pakistan because they were
trafficking women from Pakistan mainly
to the elites of the United Arab
Emirates it was probably more extensive
than that and it sort of acknowledged in
the BCCI report but what that report
documents is this Pakistan to UAE
pipeline
um and it's it's honestly very
disturbing but the way it describes what
this woman was doing in in advancing the
sex trafficking operation there very
similar to the Royal galing Maxwell
would later go on to play with with
Jeffrey Epstein I have a question about
these women and I mean Yachts boats
women I mean I grew up in South Beach
this is every weekend right this is not
a big deal at all except for this so
women I mean there's no secret guys like
beautiful women I don't think that's a
controversial topic this is the tale as
old as time but these young women these
underage women my question is this is it
used for blackmail are they a pawn in a
deeper game or are they just sick [ __ ]
that actually like younger women meaning
oh I'm I'm into 15 16 year old girls or
no we're I'm into hot women you tell
them that they're 18 20 21 whatever well
it actually turned out she was 16 dude
and we have pictures to prove it and
we're going to use it as blackmail which
one is it I think it can be it really
depends it could be both really
depending on the person I mean look at
Jeffrey Epstein and Jeffrey Epstein's
case I think he was definitely doing the
gotcha stuff and the latter stuff to
people I think that's pretty clear but
in addition you know when he uh tried to
justify himself to journalist after his
first arrest he would be like now listen
historically the age of consent wasn't
16 and it's not that weird you know once
they hit puberty like game on basically
is what he was saying and people have
pointed to um I think it's an op-ed
piece that Island dershowitz wrote um
and I think the early 2000s or late 90s
don't know the exact date but he says
something like you know it should really
be once girls start menstruating
said this yes
this is why his name constantly gets
brought up you know um I you know
there's allegations against him
obviously but he's talked about it and
he's responded to it in interviews like
people have asked very direct about it
but I think that's part of his strategy
I think he feels like if he sharks away
from it people will assume guilt and I
think he thinks he has a better chance
of you know protecting his reputation if
he confronts it head-on but I don't you
know the court of public opinion as far
as dershowitz it's concerned I think a
lot of people seem to agree with the
allegations but again it's hard to know
you know when it comes to Epstein you
know if your name gets associated with
him even Epstein acknowledged in early
2019 you know he's radioactive is the
word he used to describe himself after
his first arrest two things let's talk
about when the connection came with
Clinton and then when he met jalaine
which happened first he met jalane first
then he met yeah yeah so with Colleen
Maxwell it's publicly claimed that they
met in late 1991 or so their first
public appearance together was when he
sat next to her and her mother at a
tribute to Robert Maxwell shortly after
his death that was at the Plaza Hotel in
New York
um but you know that was sort of in my
opinion more of a coming out of their
public relationship in this close
Association that followed from that
point on of Jeffrey Epstein and Elaine
Maxwell
um I know in the book that there's
differing allegations and people are
open to make up their uh you know their
own conclusions about it that they met
years prior and there's also allegations
from people that worked with Robert
Maxwell when he was doing stuff for
Israeli intelligence including former
Israeli intelligence agents that Robert
Maxwell and Jeffrey Epstein knew each
other in the mid-1980s and worked
together on intelligent stuff and that
Colleen Maxwell
um had sort of brought Epstein into the
fold because they had some sort of
romantic relationship in this who had
the Romantic relationship Jeffrey
Epstein and galane before 1991 that's
the claim is that how you would like how
would you describe the really
relationship with their friends were
they lovers were they business partners
was it all the above was weird was it
sex I think after 1991 it was definitely
very business partner stuff there's been
a lot of this stuff out there to absolve
galane I think in a sense uh where they
say oh she was just enamored with him
and that's why she did everything I
think it's much more complicated than
that and the reason I think they've been
able to sell that narrative so well is
because they just totally ignore her
father and her relationship with her
father her father dies and she's used to
being in this particular relationship
with a man in this case her father who
dominates her life and and runs it
basically for her and has for years and
then he's dead and what does she do she
goes to someone who's just like Robert
Maxwell so it's important to find out
more about Robert Maxwell because he
himself was a very very interesting
character what do we know about Robert
Maxwell oh man well I mean we could fill
up the whole podcast
thing about Robert Maxwell to be honest
but really his intelligence connections
are a matter of record
um he was uh very closely associated
with Israeli intelligence he was also
closely associated with figures and a
Soviet and Eastern European intelligence
to a significant degree
um an alleged relationship with British
intelligence I mean it seems like he
could have been a double or triple agent
um you know very involved with
intelligence stuff and that's why it's
complicated when we talk about
intelligence affiliations oh you know
people are like um you know Robert
Maxwell was just Mossad well you know
it's more complicated than that these
people are interested in money and power
for themselves a lot of times so if it
means you know you know helping these
guys out and helping these guys out
having your hands in as many pies as
possible to rake in more money for you
and stuff like that I mean a lot of
these guys seem to do that and Robert
Maxwell was definitely a guy that sort
of seemed to not just straddle and tell
it different intelligence agencies but
also intelligence and organized crime
which is another uh big theme of the
book so looking at Robert Maxwell by the
by the 19th around the end of the 1980s
or so he went into business with Eastern
block Mobsters in a big way people like
Simeon mogulovich who whose name has
come up for example like when mainstream
media talks about Donald Trump in the
Russian mob and all of this stuff it all
goes back to Simeon mogulovich but they
won't acknowledge that he was a business
partner of Robert Maxwell and you have
Donald Trump partying on the lady galane
Robert Maxwell's yacht in in the same
period in the late 80s and all of this
stuff so is it really more of the
Maxwell Mafia or the Russian mafia right
there hasn't really been an interest in
connecting you know those dots right and
I think it's interesting too you look at
Donald Trump's reaction to Jeffrey
Epstein's arrest he wants to distance
himself I'm not a fan right and then
galane Maxwell gets arrested I wish her
well he says and people like um that
used to be pretty close to this Nexus
like Stephen hoffenberg say that Trump
was much closer to the Maxwell side than
the Epstein side from the from the
Father's Side Robert yeah and that it
continued you know that his affiliation
with Epstein and galane after Robert
Maxwell's death talking about Donald
Trump was because that he was closer to
galane than Epsy necessary well let me
ask you this how was Trump's
relationship with the Murdoch family I'm
not exactly familiar with that but but
because these guys were competitors
Maxwell and Murdoch were not we're
competitors yeah but Trump's Mentor was
Roy Cohn right and so Roy Khan had a
friendly relationship with Murdoch got
it so these guys are going at it and
this character Robert Maxwell could have
been like a great Great Gatsby character
because he would tell the stories in
half the stories you don't know if it's
real or not but I thought yeah he was uh
he's been described as like narcissistic
a very very big on self-promotion very
you know he was determined to make
himself and his family sort of like the
next Kennedys he wanted to make a
dynasty of power uh that was what he was
interested Maxwell Robert Maxwell yeah
and um one of the top FBI special agents
in New York John Patrick O'Neal uh you
know went on record saying uh that
Robert Maxwell before he died set into
motion a global Coalition of criminals
that he basically made a major
successful effort to bring together
organized crime factions from around the
world into like a Global basically
criminal conglomerate at the same time
that he has all these intelligence
affiliations and that's pretty
significant right keep going well I was
just going to say that O'Neill said you
know if you look into that guy's career
specifically you know he was sort of
head on it to be head of the security at
the World Trade Center and he started
just days before 9 11 and he was sort of
pushed out of the FBI but before he was
he left the FBI and he made these
statements to author Gordon Thomas he
said I have people looking and still
trying to unravel the Maxwell Legacy in
New York and this is a decade after
Robert Maxwell's death wow you gotta
realize that this guy was born you know
Czechoslovakian Ukraine right and then
uh uh his his parents and His Four
siblings get killed at a ashawitz I
don't know if it's a I don't know if it
was a camp but they they definitely did
die but they were also pilgrims and all
sorts of stuff
he fought against the Nazis for the
British Military and so then lay later
on he goes into wanting to compete in
media the whole mirror and then you know
he owned 51 percent of uh MTV it's kind
of weird this guy owned 51 MTV Robert he
owned 51 he was building yes
like a 51 of MTV and then this is Elaine
Maxwell's father father Robert Maxwell
so and then Elaine is the last child the
ninth yeah and his favorite after the
eldest son Uh Kevin injured in a no the
eldest son is injured I think Michael
Maxwell he dies uh after being in a
vegetative state for several years he
was the favorite Child that had this you
know awful car accident and then galane
who was uh Elaine was born around the
same time that happened with her older
brother and so uh the family basically
it neglected her for the first like
couple years of her life and she
developed like a childhood anorexia and
stuff and had a lot of problems with
feeling uh even acknowledged by her own
family which obviously is going to have
psychological stuff uh applications for
her obviously and then you know it
doubles back and then she becomes the
favorite child so you know you have that
neglect and then you go to being
favorite child you know there's a and
you sort of see Robert Maxwell start
there nine kids you sing I think it's
seven okay so all these kids was it with
the same woman and where were they all
born do you know okay yeah it was Betty
Maxwell is the the wife and very
complicated relationship there because
Robert Maxwell was not faithful
um and it doesn't seem like the kind of
guy no but she she was very faithful and
very devoted so you know yeah I feel
kind of sad for her to be honest
um but he was not faithful but he wanted
his children to be sort of like arms of
his Empire right yeah but two of them
are estranged I believe I forget their
names one went away to Argentina and the
other one uh he was not very nice to a
lot of his kids
um he was known to like verbally abuse
Evan and uh Kian and Evan uh sorry Kevin
and Ian and then um the the daughter
that's estranged he insulted her
appearance a lot and that might have
yeah is there any doubt in your mind
that he was an intelligence asset Robert
Maxwell I I just started looking into
this couple days ago because it's all
her fault I mean I literally
I'm not the first though with Robert
Maxwell Seymour Hersh published a book
called The Samson option why Robert
Maxwell was still alive alleging a
relationship with Israeli intelligence
and in in Britain the libel laws are
very strong so Robert Maxwell sued over
that intelligence claim and he did not
win did not win and by the way let's see
where Hirsch was right so we'll just
leave that there as far as I'm concerned
it's pretty it's extensively documented
the affiliation with Israeli
intelligence and and and and he names
his Yad the 50 million Auto yacht he
buys lady galane after his favorite
child after his favorite child but it's
a little weird the relationship between
Robertson right for example galane
commissions pictures for the lady galane
and some of them are a bit racy
what does that mean uh I don't know I
mean father-daughter relationship do you
really want like a picture of your
daughter with the skirt all the way up
here being like it's weird you know I'm
not saying I know anything that happened
between them but I think there was a lot
of psychological manipulation and you
know it seems like Robert Maxwell at
least in my opinion was kind of
narcissistic a lot of narcissistic
parents see no boundaries between them
and their children they see their
children as extensions of them he
believed that galane was the most
sexually attractive and the most like
him
right so you know a lack of boundaries
can mean a lot of things in that in that
particular context right and you know as
I know in the book uh chapter 15
specifically which is about all this
stuff
um it seems like he you he was
interested in using her sexuality for
his benefit
um in in a PR sort of way
um like for example would publish
stories in his own papers of alleged
Affairs of his daughter with Elite
people you know Aristocrats and Britain
and stuff like that even though you know
the British Elites that he would name
were you know denied any sort of a
romantic relationship Robert Maxwell
obviously wanted that out there and this
is the same guy who with Colleen's you
know boyfriends when she was in high
school didn't want them near the house
didn't want her to date you know was
very controlling of her romantic life
but at the same time would publish you
know basically gossip and smutty gossip
in his in his newspapers about her I can
see most dads not wanting you know your
teenage daughter around but he wanted
her to marry a Kennedy that's what he
wanted oh really really oh yeah can we
see one picture Tyler and a young Elaine
Maxwell we all know what she looks like
now
but young yeah and after no one knows
how he died suicide you know a lot of
allegations but let's look at what
Delane Maxwell says Elaine Maxwell
believes that he was murdered by Rogue
Assad agents and the Sicilian Mafia
that's what Elaine Maxwell thinks
happens to her father when does she say
that I think it's quoted in the New York
Post somewhere
um I cited in the book
she says uh he was murdered because they
you know the other children claim not
murder but she thinks she was she was
the person who according to British
journalists when he died she was the one
that came down out of all the siblings
came to the yacht right after his death
goes on the boat and shreds papers so
that means out of all the kids if that's
true out of all the kids she knew what
was incriminating and what was not where
it was and what to shred
yeah and by the way when he dies you
know who his yacht goes to his yacht
goes to Murdoch's third wife
it is interesting that's the part where
it's a very very
connection of wanting to compete in
media and how
uh the Murdoch Maxwell stuff was pretty
intense that competition uh Murdoch
drove Maxwell insane yeah looks at
things just he was he apparently was
willing to stretch his business Empire
you know as far as he could just to try
and stick Murdoch in the eye and that
that includes using 460 or 446 million
dollars of his employees retirement plan
yeah I know yeah did you hear this he
the pension fund for the for the mirror
he used his employees pension fund to
finance what he was doing with the media
company
446 million dollars and the employees
ended up only getting half of it at the
end after he died because his sons I
think Kevin and he didn't leave any he
didn't live any leave any any of his
money to uh Elaine he felt it was
appropriate to the boys or someone they
have trusts in Liechtenstein no one
knows about all right and the FBI
special agents looking at this stuff in
New York you know galane apparently came
and made the show wearing like rags and
like sobbing being like dirty being like
I have no money but they didn't believe
her
and they were trying to find about all
these trusts and stuff that you know he
he was What Jeffrey Epstein did with
money Robert Maxwell was even better so
he so he so who knows really where the
money went we don't really know a lot of
the the Maze of Robert Maxwell's funds A
lot of it is honestly still a mystery
then this is where this is where my
question goes to who had a bigger
influence on how to take Epstein's game
to the next level was it Elaine because
what she learned from her father or was
it something that apps like who brought
more to the table for the crime that
they committed both of them together was
it more Epstein's background or was it
more killing his experience well uh you
mean after Robert Maxwell's death yes so
I think Elaine was looking to continue
the same role she was sort of doing for
her Father which was being an ambassador
for her father basically in New York and
the interest that represented him his
handlers sort of looked to her and at
this time uh Jeffrey Epstein is is the
money manager for Leslie Wexner and
Leslie Wexner is affiliated with a group
of very powerful
um billionaires who at the same time
that Robert Maxwell made his inroads to
New York with galane sort of as
um uh the Ambassador
um oh sorry I lost my train oh yeah um
they're quoted in I think Vanity Fair of
having core those billionaires courting
Robert Maxwell specifically so it seems
like there was some sort of effort to
bring those interests together even
before Robert Maxwell died this name Les
Wexner if you're not familiar with it I
mean go ahead and tell I mean this is
Victoria's Secret this is the guy that
basically created the modern day
shopping mall Abercrombie and Fitch
Victoria's Secret like reveal a little
bit about this okay so I mean he he's a
retail guy so I guess the big Brands
we're familiar with yeah he's the one
that backs them but he his rise to power
is partly linked to
um people that that built the shopping
malls and the least space to him they
called him the Merlin of the mall
something of that yeah think that's a
nickname for for waxner yeah but people
like Edward uh Dave Bartolo I think is
how you pronounce it
they own the 49ers I mean this is all
coming together these were yeah yeah all
the money ladies and gentlemen yeah keep
going yeah and then Alfred Taubman who
was another big shopping he built a lot
of shopping malls he's one of the guys
that really he's considered a mentor to
Wexner asses Max Fisher and these are
guys really powerful people from Detroit
specifically involved in real estate
shopping mall stuff Max Fisher also has
a background in oil but also got into a
lot of well he's the guy that made
Taubman I guess because Todman built a
lot of I think the gas station like
convenience stores for the oil company
and then got into retail uh commercial
centers and the reason I asked about Lex
Wexner is because I went down the rabbit
hole you've done multiple interviews
with Tim Dillon right I loved him I know
like uh he's uh someone that we're in
Tatiana
he'll be he'll be here pretty soon but
I've watched multiple of your interviews
fan to Tim Dillon you know multiple
connections there but you said quote
unquote Epstein made his money from
links to three powerful men and you said
Les Wexner you said Bill Gates and then
you said Donald Trump that's not for me
that's a 2001 article from the evening
standard which is a mainstream media
publication in the UK prestigious right
and it's never been retracted it's from
2001 but if you believe U.S mainstream
media Bill Gates and Epstein didn't meet
till 2011 and this is 2001. so there's
10 years of there's more than 10 years I
think with Bill Gates and Epstein yeah
gotcha it's pretty crazy that there's an
article like that out there from 2001
and mainstream media is like 2011. what
did that article say
uh well it's it's talking so that
evening standard article is talking
mainly about prince Andrew and who are
Prince Andrew's new friends oh it's
Elaine Maxwell because obviously you
know Robert Maxwell's theft of the
pension fund money obviously had huge
ramifications in Britain a lot of people
uh for understandable reasons didn't
like the Maxwell family after that so a
lot of the gossip columns or newspapers
report a lot on what the Maxwell
children were doing they sort of became
Infamous celebrity children you know and
so they follow up on them and then
prince Andrew you know Circa 2000 or so
is going on vacation after vacation with
Colleen Maxwell and Jeffrey Epstein and
so Jeffrey Epstein is sort of introduced
in that article and they're trying to
explain to Their audience in Britain in
2001 who Epstein is because people
probably haven't heard of them yeah they
all know galane they all do prince
Andrew obviously but they don't know
Jeffrey Epstein so the introduction to
Jeffrey Epstein is he's uh they describe
him as a property developer and actually
a lot of early articles on Epstein don't
say a billionaire financial advisor like
a lot of the later ones do they say
property develop upper there's a real
estate connection there which is I sort
of explore and then in that article
what's the gates Trump connection with
all that's what they said the line there
is that this is where you know Jeffrey
Epstein's money comes from these are his
clients his top clients basically and so
people know that there was a
long-standing Wexner relationship a
long-stinning trump relationship but it
mentions Bill Gates and at the time Bill
Gates never challenged that article you
know it was never retracted like I
mentioned earlier the UK has very strong
libel laws if it was untrue he could sue
and it could be retracted today but it's
never been done when you when you're
going through the this this rabbit hole
and you're kind of researching people
you know sometimes you do this in
business you do it in sports you're
doing a lot of different things and then
all of a sudden you're you're trying to
go here then somebody makes you go here
okay you're like wait what this guy is
more interesting than these guys I was
researching who who who did that to you
while you're going through the rabbit
hole and all of a sudden there's a
personality of saying this guy
could be one of the most powerful guys
or influential guys or gals that nobody
looked at yeah I that
had a lot yeah especially in looking at
the at this web and it really is kind of
a web so you end up going in different
directions and really all those
different tangents are worth exploring
because sometimes there's very important
connections there sure yeah who anybody
um well for example let's take Leslie
Wexner right the the de Bartolo family
um had an affiliation with waxner and
it's actually mentioned in a police
report from Columbus Ohio that they have
organized crime connections and it
discusses that Leslie Wexner by
extension has several organized crime
connections himself right so you know I
didn't that particular police report you
know has a lot of very interesting
information about Leslie wexner's
business connections and his business
associates but then you know if you go
beyond that and you look at those names
that come up there on their own you find
a lot more information at the organized
crime connections are a lot more
extensive for example than they are in
the police report and and things like
that or maybe things I've done more
recently since that report was written
um you know it's really worth that
leaving now you know what's crazy in
these cases have you ever watched the
show It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
ever uh yeah but yeah it's an amazing
show but yeah to your point Tyler pull
up this picture I just sent you
tell me if you've ever seen this image
uh if we could pull it up
but this is what essentially Pat's
question reminds me of that you're doing
that anyone who's ever watched this show
oh it's uh you've seen this yeah sure I
mean it's like making a murder
documentary going down the rabbit hole
this is what comes to mind this is where
I'm at right now yeah but yeah but some
people use the Simmons right to be like
oh everyone that looks at this kind of
stuff and claims there's any sort of web
or like decentralized power structure
with real pull is insane you know and
it's sort of this claim when you get
called a conspiracy theorist right it's
sort of this idea that all the stuff
we're talking about today it's just a
coincidence these people have no agency
they don't actually you know plan to
expand their power and wealth behind
closed doors and I think that's honestly
pretty naive I saw this comedian
yesterday you know how somebody sends me
this clip what a funny
African-American weren't wearing a suit
this thing went viral funny funny I wish
I knew the guys in to give him credit uh
if I find out I'll put it on Instagram
for people to see it so he says listen I
understand not believe in most
conspiracy theories but you mean to tell
me you are willing to believe that all
of them are conspiracy theories just
have a problem with that there's no way
in the world all conspiracy theories are
wrong no way there has to be some of
them that are right he says look here
you have the government that's filled by
thousands of powerful people hundreds of
powerful people and there's 330 million
of them of us right that they're gonna
lie to us it says look I got a son I
love my son
I love him more than anybody in the
world and I want him to live an
incredible life but I got to tell you
he's got one person above him as a
father and it's me and I lied to that
kid all the time that's the one right
there you send it to me oh my God that
was hilarious I couldn't stop laughing
let's put the link below if people says
he lies to the kids he says I like to I
lied to my kid all the time is what
makes you think if I as a parent lie to
my kid all the time government's not
lying to us about different conspiracy
theories says you have to be naive to
not believe some of these things that
could be true fully agree you know but
but they put the label and then they
discredit somebody that's writing and
saying what they're saying and they take
one part of it that you got drunk and
automatically they say everything else
she said Snopes mostly false thing and
it's like no it was mostly true yeah but
one little false but think about today
if you're saying something that's true
but the government calls it a conspiracy
theory you can lose uh if you're someone
like me you can lose your income you can
be taken off of patreon you can be taken
off of Twitter Facebook YouTube where
did you get taken off taken off of
patreon yeah patreon took you off what
was their reason uh it's comp well I
wrote an article about the affiliations
of the creator of the AstraZeneca covet
vaccine and that he was Affiliated in
speaking to the Galton Institute which
was until 1989 the British Eugenics
society and some of the affiliations of
that particular organization uh so
anyway they didn't like that I mean
Eugenics we can have a whole
conversation about that oh yeah yeah but
I got to tell you you know I'm on on Pat
show on our show uh I'm sort of the
skeptic we have 9 11. they're you know
conspiracy theories guys we've got
obviously coveted stuff we've had
pre-sawn that exercise demons Q Anon
type stuff and I'm very skeptical on
this I'm not skeptical at all I'm like
okay question I think I think you're
Savvy enough to know that a lot of this
stuff makes sense when we're talking
about the politics of power and you're
about follow the money yes exactly yeah
that's my point is that it's you know
people want to get political ideology
this has nothing to do with politics but
I mean Democrat becomes just follow the
freaking money here and think about that
with Epstein this is a guy that's so
Infamous everyone in America probably
knows his name but no one knows that he
committed Financial crimes oh it's he's
a sex trafficker that's what we need
he's just a sex trafficker no he's a
finance but this is the guy that was
involved in one of the biggest Ponzi
schemes in the U.S history with Towers
Financial even though he was named as
being The Mastermind of that during
grand jury proceedings his name is
dropped from the case and he ends up at
Bill Clinton fundraisers in 1993. and
then after that some of the most
controversial fundraisers and Bill
Clinton's uh presidential career
Epstein's there and then after Clinton
leaves office he's setting up the
Clinton Foundation flying on Epstein's
plane around Africa he credits Epstein
for coming up with his HIV AIDS
philanthropy uh being involved in
creating the Clinton Health Access
initiative you know and a lot of people
have sort of you know argued that the
Clinton Foundation is sort of a
glorified political slush fund for the
Clinton family so why do you have a
financial criminal helping you set up
your your foundation after he's involved
with the most controversial actually
fundraisers of your of your political
career after being involved in a major
Ponzi scheme after being a financial
Bounty Hunter involved in the Offshore
Banking complex
it's complicated stuff there's no
interest in looking at this stuff except
for maybe the Daily Mail I'll give you
uh some examples so uh The Daily Beast
around the time that Epstein was
arrested the second time uh came out and
and noted that Epstein had attended at
least five meetings at the Clinton White
House with a guy named Mark Middleton
okay
um last December the Daily Mail obtained
the full visitor logs that number
ballooned to 17. it wasn't covered in
the U.S
shouldn't that matter that it goes from
5 to 17 you have this guy in less than
around two years going to the White
House 17 times and he's not just meeting
with Mark Middleton his first meeting
was Robert Rubin a former head of
Goldman Sachs
who by the way Goldman Sachs was accused
of being a major accessory to Robert
Maxwell's Financial crimes including the
stuff with the Pension funds and all of
that were involved in all of this crazy
stuff so the guy that is part you know
running basically the bank that Robert
Maxwell is very much tied to Robert
Maxwell dies and the first guy to bring
Jeffrey Epstein into the White House is
that Banker
so so go go to the clintons go to the
clintons you were talking about
everything with the clintons why do so
many people when it comes down to
Clinton's get suicided uh you know I
don't have an answer for that but I mean
I can give you my opinion yeah that's
what I want to hear why we hear these
stories and then you know I want I want
to ask you whether you feel Trump has
any kind of a involvement with Epstein
not in regards to business but with
women because I have my own Theory there
as well but let's start off with the
clintons first uh okay so the Clinton
stuff is really complicated and even I
like with the book you know I sort of
saved some of that stuff for last and I
it probably should be its own book
because this Mark Middleton guy most of
his meetings were with Mark Middleton
um you have these visitor logs came out
right last December at 17 visits it's
much more than five with Mark Middleton
and then just a few months later Mark
Middleton dies in Little Rock Arkansas
uh he was allegedly found hanging by the
neck from a with an extension cord
around his neck and a shotgun wound to
the chest and it was labeled suicide
provide a local Court in orcas Arkansas
said that no media uh front taken at the
scene photos videos anything is allowed
to be released to the public oh what he
was hanging supposedly
this is again from the Daily Mail citing
local law enforcement that you know it's
it's very crazy
I mean listen if you can commit suicide
by hanging yourself and shooting
yourself with a shotgun in the chest
you're a magician is what you are I mean
you're you're in a league of Europe yeah
and so this is right after it comes out
that he's you know meeting the guy that
met with Epstein a bunch of the Clinton
white house but it's even crazier than
that because you once you start looking
into who Mark Middleton was at the White
House it gets crazy really fast I'll
give you an example George W bush comes
into office are you familiar with the
first time Bush invoked executive
privilege
uh among other things I think there were
three things in the particular document
that was you know that invocation but
one of those three was all documents
about Mark Middleton not going to
Congress which was investigating Mark
Middleton why did Bush step in to
protect a Aid to the Chief of Staff of
the White House for Clinton who's
normally you know he's not a big fish
right yeah what was it why is Bush
stepping in for that what's your thing
well uh if you look into why Mark
Middleton was Infamous at that time and
why he was being investigated it's
remembered really only by U.S
conservatives today and they refer to it
as China Gate
um which is kind of a largely forgotten
political Scandal it's insane once you
get into it I personally think China I
think China gets kind of a misnomer you
you do have China involved but really
it's the same it's some of the families
that backed Bill Clinton uh when he was
governor of Arkansas uh the reality
family Jackson Stevens these types of
figures uh when Bill Clinton becomes
president they have a lot of interest in
uh China stuff and and mainly it looks
sort of like a lot of tech transfer
stuff to China and so it can service at
the time said it was basically the the
clintons selling out uh U.S national
security on a major scale to uh the
Chinese government or mainly uh to firms
that were you know state-backed and tied
up with the the Chinese military
um and uh Mark Middleton was one of the
guys at the center of this and Epstein's
meeting with him at the same time that
China Gates active and oddly enough in
the same period of time and I mean this
is why it's so crazy uh Jeffrey Epstein
on behalf of Leslie Wexner is involved
in moving an airline called Southern Air
transport from Miami Florida to Columbus
Ohio to run cargo for The Limited and um
sorry I got away from the microphone and
that's the airline that used to be air
America the CIA Airline and Southern Air
transport was involved in the Iran
Contra stuff moving stuff the Mena
Arkansas Barry seal the cocaine stuff
all of that was Southern Air transport
and then just a few years later it
becomes the airline of the limited and
it's not going from Miami to Latin
America anymore it's going from Columbus
Ohio involved with Epstein Wexner it's
going to Hong Kong
and this is the guy at the same period
of time he's meeting with the China Gate
guy I mean there's a lot of really crazy
stuff here and honestly it would take
the whole podcast to unravel it all I've
tried to do my best in the book but
there's there's really a lot more there
and it's it's very crazy and the other
guy at the center of this was Commerce
Secretary Ron Brown who agreed to
cooperate with an investigation and do a
lot of this stuff and then he ends up
dead in a plane crash that kills a bunch
of people in the Commerce Department
that are at the exact part of Commerce
ITA at the Commerce Department who were
that was basically the department most
targeted by this particular group for
China Gate is this the one where 34
people died and they said there was a
radar failure and then the next day the
radar failure guy was killed or he has
uh he had a yeah he was shot in the
chest and it was real to Suicide
it was in Croatia Ron Brown uh after he
agreed to investigate was was told he
needed to go on a you know urgent trade
mission to Croatia and that's when the
crash happens and I think I actually
Maxine Waters at the time I requested
there be further investigation because
he was found with an odd wound in his
head that was consistent with a gunshot
wound and the x-rays disappeared and a
lot of crazy Maxine Waters wanted it to
be investigated yeah well actually like
when Gary Webb wrote a you know dark
Alliance and all this stuff she also
called for their doing investigation but
that doesn't mean it went anywhere you
know Maxine Waters congresswoman well I
think she was a bit different in the 90s
than she is now yeah no question let me
just bring this down to earth for a
second because obviously we can go the
whole Charlie Day yeah but the Clinton
stuff's really crazy yeah right yeah you
know all these theories and and the
stuff that we're hearing and we had a
whole conversation about distrust of the
media you know the the stories about
politics and Clinton's and the media and
the lies and the money and not trusting
what you're seeing not taking things at
face value
how should the average person I'm just a
normal American I'm just a normal
citizen paying my bills got my family
how should they process just the news in
your opinion you mean like mainstream
media yeah just you know living my life
I'm just hearing you know doing what I'm
doing um I think mainstream media has uh
evolved a lot over the past few decades
right I think uh you know I I've been
out of the U.S this is my first time
back in the US in like eight years my
parents I was at their house a few days
ago they watched the evening news all
the time like ABC and when they're
talking about a government story they
just cite the government sources and
that's all they say they don't you know
look to see if it's true they don't do
any sort of Watchdog stuff they're just
telling you uh what the official story
is about really anything and you know to
me that's being more of a stenographer
than being a journalist I don't want to
be a normal person right now I want to
be an abnormal person and go back to
Clinton so let's go back to Clinton's
okay so we did Middleton we did Ron
Brown who else when you see the link to
these guys Esther you got a few of these
guys that you can I mean it's just it's
so nuts I mean I would encourage people
to read this part of the book because
there's so much detail it's so
convoluted and insane when you get into
the the stuff about this and even the
Congressional reports that were done
about China Gate I mean it's totally
insane what happened uh it's very like
illegal and there was a focus on the
illegal campaign donations but it was
basically like pay for play politics but
it was pay for play politics where these
illegal campaign donations were being uh
obtained from non-us citizens and it was
basically buying influence of the
Commerce Department that was seems to
have been signing off on basically Tech
transfers of sensitive like military and
other types of Technology uh to our
ostensible adversary and when it wasn't
supposed to be sent over there and also
stuff about China's trading status like
most favored nation trading status
because Clinton campaigned on playing
Hardball with the Chinese out that stuff
and he totally reversed right and a lot
of this is because of this this one
family that backed his political career
going way back named the riyadis that
are actually Indonesian but they're
ethnic Chinese and they have a lot of
business interests and all of Southeast
Asia they're very big they're called the
Lipo group and um the Lipo group in in
Jackson Stevens these guys have a
relationship with BCCI that we mentioned
we talked about earlier back in the
1980s and actually tried to save the
BCCI Hong Kong Branch before its
collapse and that's when they went into
business uh with some of these Chinese
government-owned firms and that's where
China Gate really starts and it gets
really crazy from from there on out but
talking even not talking about China
Gate anymore you look at the first time
Epstein went to a Clinton fundraiser it
was supposed to be for the White House
historical Association not only a
fundraiser so Hillary Clinton could
redecorate parts of the White House
um
I don't even I feel crazy talking about
it just because it's so insane but this
fundraiser Epstein was involved in he
was one of the donors to that you also
have one of the guys instrumental in
BCCI stuff like Clark Clifford uh who
was in the Carter Administration and
played a major role in bcci's entry into
the U.S financial system
um and then you have a guy named C
Gerald Goldsmith who tried to run for
mayor of Palm Beach once who has a bunch
of ties to Offshore Banking complex
organized crime I mean a lot of the guys
not everyone obviously but some of the
guys that attended this fundraiser are
Financial guys like that right and this
fundraiser ends up in Vince Foster's
suicide note
what does that mean are you familiar
with Vince Foster yeah of course he was
White House counsel
um and Clinton yeah and he died and uh
there's a lot of speculation about what
really happened there
because you know he supposedly shot
himself in the mouth but there's no
blood at the scene right
and uh the autopsy report said it was a
mouth to neck wound and then they
changed it you know on some pages it
says that on some pages it says like you
know it was a regular
gunshot wound and then the people that
were at the scene are advised about the
autopsy late and they show up and all
the part of the mouth and neck the
palate all this stuff is just taken out
of Vince Foster so they can't look at it
or yeah there's a lot of weird stuff
going on there I mean I know I know you
know the specifics about the the death
in in the book and why people
suspect something but it's pretty much a
matter of record that when police went
into Vince Foster's office after his
body was found there was nothing in his
briefcase and then somehow like 36 I
think hours later the White House claims
there was a suicide note that Vince
Foster left and it was apparently
Hillary Clinton's office that was
responsible for finding that suicide
note after this extensive delay and the
only mention of Hillary Clinton in that
suicide note is related to this White
House historical Association fundraiser
so these crazy stories about the
clintons and all the all these they've
done this and suicide it's like in their
smoke there's fire kind of a thing these
oh yeah there's credibility here I got a
question about that that we were kind of
talking about yesterday remember how you
were saying Deutsche Bank we were
talking Deutsche about yeah
Salas Esther Salas what happened with
her as a judge and her son so I haven't
followed up since the the shooting
happened to be honest so I'm not
actually sure how that case has advanced
or not but I know that the case was
about to be heard Esther Salas was the
judge overseeing uh the case related to
uh Deutsche bank's relationship with
Epstein and how despite staff uh you
know red flagging lots of stuff that he
was involved with nothing happened to
him at that particular Bank
um and there was a shooting at her home
her teenage son was murdered
um and really if you think about it
since Epstein's second arrest and the
case became Infamous that's the only
innocent person to die
yeah so and that's related to the
Epstein's finances this is again why I
say the financial crimes there's a
reason this stuff is underreported
but but the part of the story that I
want to bring back to Clinton's and some
of these other guys is the following so
guy shows up as a delivery man shoots
the sun wounds to a husband son dies
uh while this whole thing is going on
with epsteinth and Deutsche Bank and
then the shooter the next day or not the
next day the same day uh is found in a
car with a dead dead with a bullet wound
and he he killed himself right after he
killed him that's the narrative so you
know some people have speculated is it
even the guy that did the shooting or
was it just pinned on him or you know
who knows
um and if you look into the guy who is
is the alleged shooter he um previously
worked for a group called Kroll
Associates which is known as the CIA of
Wall Street they did Security on World
Trade Center during 9 11. they also
investigated many scandals of this
particular group I write about in the
books and then found no wrongdoing even
if they acknowledge uh wrongdoing in the
bulk of the report their summary is
everything's fine you know they
investigated people like um at Nan
khashoggi and Imelda Marcos uh for all
those financial things uh I think
Covenant House
um Lots stuff Robert Maxwell hired them
right before his death uh very
interesting for him to say the least and
actually French intelligence alleged a
few times that they were an actual front
for the CIA Coral Associates but if you
look at you know who's made the you know
made up a lot of their staff
historically in terms of intelligence
connections it seems to come mostly from
either U.S or Israeli intelligence at
crawl Association how many how many
murders are linked back to Clinton's
what's the number I have no idea but I'm
sure people like all sorts of stuff to
them and I think you know there are some
that we could link and then there are
some that maybe you're a little more
speculative depending on who's making
the list here's my question you know I'm
going to be the the skeptic here and my
question is the following so if somebody
does things like this
um you know like RFK when I asked them
about the murder of his father Robert
Kennedy yeah he went on he wrote a book
about it on what they did to him and his
uncle right I mean if something like
that happens to you that closely to you
you're probably going to spend the rest
of your life wanting to find out what
happened yeah get to the bottom of it
right okay
are most people going to want to seek
Vengeance I don't know of course most
will not most are going to be like oh
you know I'm gonna do something and
they're not gonna do anything about it
and life kind of goes on uh you know in
in most of most you know tragic events
that happens people generally move on a
couple years later and life kind of
happens you're worried about well it's
going to affect the other kids this this
that so I'm not going to do anything
about it but if you've ever seen that
one movie when Gerard Butler what's the
movie's name uh we were talking about a
yesterday law-abiding citizen where
somebody kills his daughter and his wife
and he goes and buys the building next
to the prison and goes and finds the
person that killed his wife and his
daughter and he seeks Vengeance right
yeah if something like this has happened
with Epstein or with you know Clinton's
why hasn't anybody done something about
it whether it's a lawyer whether people
have tried whether you think we don't
hear about them take for example Mina
Arkansas you know we talked about
earlier Southern transport Berry seal
the cocaine the Contra stuff that was
going on there were some kids that ended
up dead near near there under suspicious
circumstances and the mother of one of
those boys
I feel really bad I can't remember her
name because she's suffered so much and
worked so hard to try and find out what
was going on there
um just decades trying to get to the
bottom of it and trying to find out what
who killed her son what was neat city in
Arkansas uh well it was this is Mina
Arkansas so m-e-n-a we're talking about
but I think the exact location where
they either lived or were found is a
different city right next to it crazy
tying all this together remember when we
sat down with the drug trafficker for
Pablo Escobar what was his name uh Roger
Reeves didn't he talk about Barry seal
and Mina Arkansas wasn't that a theme
with the Escobar the drug running wasn't
that a thing there was a lot of drugs is
that accurate yeah yes what the
well it's well here's basically what
happened I mean this is sort of like a
very simplified summary of major aspects
of Iran Iran Contra which is you know of
course it's it's very complex but
basically you know Bill Casey a cedar
CIA director was told by Congress you
can only send humanitarian Aid to the
contras he had set up this major
military support apparatus for the
contras in Nicaragua and he was like
well you know how do I get around this
how do I get around Congress so I can
Finance
whatever covert operation I want without
Congress having to fund me you know how
do I undermine them basically you know
so I can keep doing what I want what I
think is best and screw what Congress
thinks or screw what the president
thinks even right
and how do you finance that
you know uh it gets complicated it seems
like some of the stuff they went towards
was stuff like arms traffic trafficking
drug trafficking
maybe there's allegations of human
traffic but who really knows right I
have a hard time like somebody not
making this their life mission to be a
lot of times you are like you ask uh
Rudy Giuliani why'd you become a lawyer
well because when who his dad was what
his dad did what his family was linked
to how he was around the mob how he
could have been in the mob and he chose
to be a lawyer one of my good friends
became a cop in La his his brother was a
criminal and I we were these are kids we
went high school with and he says listen
he told his brother one day in front of
everybody he's the younger brother he
says I'm going to become a cop and I
swear to God if I find you in the
streets I'm going to put your ass in
jail and I love you so he became a cop
because his older brother was a criminal
and he was in and out of jail he was
sick of seeing what he was doing to his
mother so the younger brother took the
pain of mom crying every single night
because the older brother being a
criminal he said I want to be a cop till
today he's 44 years old he's a cop so
there has to be if these stories are
true and they're emotionally connected
to the kid or someone's going to be a
lawyer someone's going to say I'm going
to be to give my life to this look at
100 more Hunter more is the Revenge of
porn guy I don't know if you followed
this guy's story his Netflix documentary
came out the most hated man on the
internet the most hated man on the
internet if you don't know this guy he
would get boyfriends that would send the
nude photos of their girlfriends exes
and he would put it on a website he was
making a bunch of money on this website
and eventually a bunch of people are
begging him to take their pictures down
I'm not taking your pictures down your
ex gave it to you good for you LOL you
can't do [ __ ] wait do you see I can get
more pictures from your ex about you and
all this stuff he eventually gets caught
goes to jail right and Anderson Cooper's
interview in this guy 11 years ago do
you feel guilty about it not really do
you know what eventually happens a
mother okay named Charlotte laws found
her daughter's new picture under his
website asked him to take it down he
never took it down she's the reason he
went to jail one mother dedicated her
life to take this guy down and she won
so if all of these stories are true
about the clintons if all of these
stories are true about the epsteins if
all these stories are true and families
are connected
suicides people love those people kids
love their dad their moms someone's got
to do something about it how come nobody
has well in the case of the person
you're talking about did the guy running
that website have major intelligence
connections did he have major
connections to some of the wealthiest
most powerful people on Wall Street
probably not probably not right so you
know it really depends on you know who
you're going up against I don't know
about that I I think if something like
that happened a kid would dedicate their
lives to politics office being a
billionaire being an influential person
but again I think it depends on the kit
take it like Ron Brown's son Ron Brown's
son went into went into politics and was
just like his dad sort of because Ron
Brown was pretty corrupt you know he did
end up getting killed because he agreed
to cooperate but only because you know
he was at the end they had a lot of
stuff on him right who's Ron Brown I
think he's Ron Brown Jr I can't remember
but he ended up being a corrupt
politician uh even after what happened
to his father and I think I can't
remember exactly I think it was a much
smaller he wasn't National politics it
was either like city or state or
something but he ended up getting caught
for some I don't know if it was bribery
but something along that the specifics I
don't remember but he just kind of went
to the same business his dad was in and
maybe he was like well you know maybe
something happened to my dad but you
know I saw how my dad was before and he
made a lot of money and I want to make
let me ask you this let me ask a
question let's just say you are I'm
gonna come to you you are the daughter
of any of these guys okay that were
suicided okay hypothetically but I would
fight but I don't know if everyone's
like me you know what I mean some people
are like but what would you do let's
just say I want to use you so what would
you do say say you're one of those
people it's not like you're going to go
be a UFC fighter find these guys in the
streets and fight them no it's hard how
would you go about doing it you're a 22
year old daughter of one of these guys
at the clintons Epstein's they did
something to him or you're this the
sister of one of the I would try girls
that Epstein picked up and he put on
this island or the house what would you
do I would try and get people in Media
to tell my story right but what if the
media won't touch the story that you're
trying to get out there
will they have you on maybe but not not
a big podcast and we'll beg your podcast
pick it up I don't know I think it
depends again you know why did
mainstream media not want to cover the
fact that Epstein
um went to the White House with Clinton
17 times why did they not cover the fact
that you know last December the picture
finally came out of Bill Clinton and
Jeffrey Epstein shaking hands in 1993
but they claimed for you know a couple
years that they didn't meet until you
know after Clinton was out of office and
wasn't president anymore
why will they not look into the fact
that Bill Gates says oh we only met for
the first time in 2011 but there's
documentation that they knew each other
at least a decade prior if not longer
you know they're
you know I think there are people who
will try and fight but sometimes you
know what if someone does try and go on
a podcast and then they get a knock at
the door and it's like you can't talk to
people anymore unless you want what
happened to your father to happen to you
or something you would eventually be
silenced as well well I don't know but I
think all you mean about my work I'm
saying you no no no no no no I'm saying
you're the daughter you're the sister of
somebody I think some people what if
they try and do something and they get
threatened okay so okay so that happens
to you happens to you audience if you're
listening happens to you comment in this
what do you do something happens to you
okay
somebody did this to your mom okay
somebody did this to you what would your
long-term plan be I'm asking a very
serious question here I'm glad you used
the word long term because I think short
term everyone's going to be filled with
anger and Vengeance you're not going to
get to it this has to be a long-term
exactly and it's got to be through
career law politics business what would
you do you have to dedicate your life to
revenge is what it comes to you're like
Batman at that point right short term
everyone's going to be angry and upset
and want to get Vengeance but Batman has
the resources right he's Bruce Wayne
he's super rich he's got all this
technology he's got this big company
behind him what if you're just a regular
person what kind of resources do you
have what if no one wants to have you on
their podcast what if you can't get
anyone to tell your story yeah as
emotional and as distraught and as
Revenge stricken as you are at some
point most people or most people are
just like [ __ ] it it's not worth it and
they give up but I mean think about
Esther Salas who we talked about a
little bit more her you know her sons
killed her husband's almost killed how
are you gonna rule in that case
as a judge
I said judge
what are you gonna do
they've already taken the most important
thing from you
but but what's the purpose of life at
that point though
you know what what is the you know at
that at that point of the game like you
know I think what they're trying to say
is don't [ __ ] with the mob yeah I don't
know about it no no I think there are
certain people that don't roll that way
I think there are certain I think there
are certain people but is that everyone
I don't think it's everyone I think
there's some people maybe like you like
me like you that would fight and do
everything but I don't know if that's
everyone you know what I mean some
people you know just want to be left
alone was there a while we all watched
The Man on Fire that's kind of what this
reminds me of I remember the exact
premise of that but I'm actually not
going that direction I'm actually not
going that direction to seek Vengeance
to kill but because in that situation he
didn't kill the brother he you know the
the devil he didn't kill the brother he
shot the brother's hand and then he gave
up his own life in exchange for Dakota
Fanning right because greasy was uh
Denzel and he gave the exchange to find
out if she's alive go ask him what she
calls her teddy bear hey what do you
call the teddy bear I call the teddy
bear greasy she calls it teddy bear
greasy boom that's the point of the the
story changes right inflection point
where you're like oh my God she's alive
okay what do you want I want your life
but I don't know like all I'm thinking
about is if all this stuff is true and
it doesn't because by the way not all of
it needs to be true if 20 of it is true
with all these personalities we hear
about suicide and killing I don't need a
hundred percent of it to be true I need
10 to be 20 20 to be true and they're
not held accountable for it you have so
if this is all about the clintons right
let's keep in mind a lot of people that
are on this you know alleged suicided
list are people that work with the
clintons and also were involved in
allegedly a lot of shady stuff so is
there you know element of dirt to that
as well you know you see what I'm saying
like
um let's see someone like Vince Foster
right allegedly Vince Foster's sister
there was like some money exchange and
stuff before his death and like maybe
what if the family the broader family is
sort of tied up in this stuff too do you
think they're gonna fight if someone
gets killed that's close to them
if they're also sort of involved in the
Shady world
I mean everybody no no you're right I
agree that's not everybody but you know
you're talking about the clintons it's
not like everyone that's on that suicide
list is like equally innocent as others
you know so it gets really complicated
and convoluted but again I don't think
you know unfortunately you know I didn't
do a lot of research into their families
and what they've done since then I do
know that like there's that that Mom
from the kid that was killed near me
Arkansas that's been fighting for since
the 80s yeah really and there are some
people like that but is everyone on that
on that list gonna be like that you know
it's hard it's hard to know and it's
it's hard to know in this case too I
mean you take someone like Jeffrey Epson
being suicidal there's his brother but
his brother seems to have been involved
in a lot of this stuff and maybe he just
doesn't want to get asked by the same
person that might have asked his brother
you know what do you think it would take
to get jelene to speak and actually
speak speak what do you think I don't
think it'll happen
but what do you all the money in the
world wouldn't do it uh no I don't think
it would have to be money I think there
would have to be Mass disclosure of what
was actually going on and then maybe
she'd talk about it but she not be the
first to talk about it no way so so
she's in a very vulnerable situation she
got moved sort of like to a country club
prison probably because she agreed to
not talk right
yeah so so you think she's done done
she'll never talk I will not get
anything no no way no way don't you
think her talking helps her set herself
free if she does talk because it's now
out in the open I don't think it is all
out in the open no if she does though if
she does actually go out there and say
no I don't know it's hard to know she
thinks she thinks her father was
murdered she thinks Jeffrey Epstein was
probably murdered
so I mean I've just pointed again what's
the purpose of living so why not talking
you'd have to ask her I mean she thinks
maybe she thinks yeah
yeah not exactly see see what she's okay
so now let's go to the Trump situation
so you you openly talk a lot about Trump
it's not like you're holding back
because you're not a republican you're
not a Democrat I don't even know
politically I want to put you anything
you're just objective about everything
what do you think Trump's involvement is
was this well I definitely think you
know mainstream media likes to focus on
either Epstein Trump or Epstein Clinton
I think the Epstein Clinton relationship
is far more damaging than the Epstein
Trump relationship I think the Epstein
Trump relationship
um was mainly a social one I don't
really you know the Clinton stuff is I
mean we just kind of got into that and
it's pretty wild right the Epstein Trump
stuff doesn't seem to be that crazy in
comparison but you have to keep in mind
too like I think a lot of people whether
you love them or you hate them you end
up sort of coming at his background and
who he is from sort of a biased
standpoint if you're on one of those two
polarized extremes that we have today in
the United States right yeah yeah
totally so as I see it you know I wrote
a lot about his mentor Roy Cohn and that
kind of world and that's the person who
supposedly taught him you know the art
of the deal and we talked a little bit
earlier about this favor bank system
unsavory alliances you're working in
real estate the you know cement concrete
it's mob-dominated companies you gotta
you know make unsavory alliances this is
to make your business work and you know
this is a guy you know Trump is a guy
that inherited a real estate Empire
already there he obviously wants it to
succeed so he's going to continue that
same system right and he's going to
continue making those same alliances and
do what he can to be a businessman and
do it in his mind is you know be
successful right so I think that's sort
of how you get you know the Trump we
have today but then again you have Trump
uh have a major bankruptcy in the early
90s the bank that rescues him uh is Ross
child Inc which is the Wall Street
branch of the European banking family
and that particular Bank was also
very close to Robert Maxwell it was also
very close to a guy named Sir James
Goldsmith it's also one of these
corporate Raiders from this period of
time in the 80s and actually Jeffrey
Epstein had a relationship with him
Goldsmith as early as like 1973
1971 somewhere in that ballpark so that
connection goes very far back actually
but Ross child Inc the the guy that was
in charge of it was a Robert Peary I
believe his name is and so Robert Peary
decided to specifically recruit sometime
in the 1980s Maxwell and Goldsmith and I
think another associate of Maxwell and
this is coming from the New York Times
by the way
um as to sort of help them grow their
mergers and Acquisitions business that
was it was the Rothschild family sort of
Saw Ross child Inc as sort of a
neglected branch of their banking you
know Empire thank you and um and they
wanted they tasked this Robert Peary guy
was sort of growing it and developing it
and so he brought in Maxwell and these
guys right and so this is um one of the
banks that that's responsible for Robert
Maxwell's deal with MacMillan for
example and MacMillan is believed to to
really be the way that Robert Maxwell
got his foot first in the door of uh in
New York City specifically
um because of their you know interest
there macmillan's interest there and so
then you have that same bank that's very
tied up with Robert Maxwell and these
characters uh rescue Trump from
bankruptcy so by the way if you're
watching this uh rescue Trump from
bankruptcy so by the way if you're
watching this if you think this message
needs to be heard by others give it a
thumbs up and share with others because
that's going to help with the algorithms
if you think this is a message and we're
going to give the links to her book as
well at the end but you know why I don't
believe he has anything going and the
media would love to find something with
him and Epstein because if you did you
would have never done this on the debate
stage Trump pulls out a stunt and brings
out you know uh uh the the ladies that
he brought up I'm sure you remember this
when he brought Apollo Jones and
Kathleen Wiley and Juanita Broderick
there's no way you do that if you have
any link to Epstein because this is if
you do this a hundred times more of this
is coming back to you totally well like
I mentioned earlier the Epstein Clinton
relationship far more damaging than the
Epstein Trump relationship so if it's
Trump versus Clinton you know who's
going to want to bring up Epstein first
really neither of them I think uh
because again this unsavory Alliance
System it looks like Trump sort of did
that to an extent you know with Epstein
but like I sort of touched on earlier it
seems like he was closer to the Maxwell
or a bit of stuff right
um and that may be because of this bank
that may be because he was on the lady
galane and had sort of these this the
stuff with you know allegedly was Simeon
mogulovich or Robert Maxwell business
partner in organized crime guy and all
this stuff but again unsavory alliances
you know you have in order to be on top
in that dog eat dog world you know where
Trump inhabits right in New York City
you know maybe you have to do some
things that aren't so nice right
this challenge it's a challenging thing
because once you uh come into Fame and
money you get invited to parties all the
time and you don't know what party
you're going because typically here's
how the party invitation sounds like the
party invitation goes and says there's
gonna be a lot of who's who's at this
yacht party it's a Monaco style yacht
party it's a party being hosted at xyz's
house and you're like okay go I'll go to
the party yeah but then you go to the
party and the next thing you know
pictures are being taken and then
afterwards hey such and such was that
this person's part dude I just got an
invite I don't I don't know anybody it's
hard to know but you know you got to
follow the money right that's a
different story following the money is a
different story once you do business
with somebody that's a different story
then you're invited to a party but
sometimes like there's even a picture
with jillane Maxwell Elon Musk so hey
look at the picture here within I don't
know if you've seen this one or not sure
sure it's from 2014 yeah so he's had a
party well she took pictures with a lot
of people even like Robert F Kennedy Jr
took pictures with her but they're as
far as I understand not really
Affiliated at all so I mean she was a
social butterfly she was very much in
these um Elite New York
Social Circles and you know that was
really what she did she was an
influencer right and you know there are
times when she used that to advance you
know these this particular side of
things that we're talking about the
shadier stuff but some of it may have
just been social again it's really hard
to know but you know if you look like I
did at some of these articles that came
out in mainstream media before Epstein
was Infamous even arrested the first
time
I mean it's pretty clear that people in
the Social Circles knew something was
weird with Colleen Maxwell and Jeffrey
Epstein uh there's talk and I think it's
a 2003 article from UK media talking
about how Colleen Maxwell there were
rumors that she would take yeah young
blonde girls and train them in sex
techniques and how to use whips and
stuff who would do this Colleen Maxwell
This is in like mainstream media before
he was even first arrested if that's
trickling into mainstream media reports
far back then somebody knew and someone
was trying to say something but
you know didn't really do much I guess I
have a question before I I want to stay
I want you to stay on Trump and all this
but because I'm shifting gears a little
bit but
um you know these days Kanye's in the
news for a lot of anti-Semitic comments
sure and
um you know I'm Jewish so I you know you
know anti-Semitism what hold on and then
it's like I'm actually hearing what he's
saying and he's kind of just emphasizing
his point about what's happening in
Black America and it's not so much
against Jews and he had a very you know
interesting dialogue with Lex Friedman
who's a very intellectual podcaster if
you've ever heard of him you're a very
smart guy very stoic and very rational
but he kind of some of the things he was
saying about Jews almost triggered Lex
to start cursing and get emotional uh
but my question stems from the point
that they got at is he's like Jews
didn't screw you Kanye individuals did
when you start calling out groups of
people and not individuals that will
breed to hate when you start calling out
individuals sure you know you can can
kind of work on the the problem but so
as a Jew I'm kind of grappling with that
well here's my question is this though
like you hear Rothschilds Jewish banking
family Epstein sure Jewish Delane
Maxwell her family Jewish okay right
would you you know I here's the thing if
you're talking about Israeli
intelligence do you think I'm talking
about all Jewish people if I'm talking
about the CIA I'm talking about all
Americans exactly if I'm talking about
uh Italian Mobsters you think I'm
talking about all Italian people Jewish
Mobsters all Jewish people there's a
conflation here and I think there are
some people who use that to to their
advantage maybe before Epstein was
arrested the first time if he were to go
talk about Leslie Wexner organized crime
allegations uh allegations that he was
uh involved with the murder of his tax
attorney in 1985. you could have been
called an anti-semite by some people but
again I don't think that's uh Fair
because then you're conflating someone
involved in criminal activity with all
Jewish people I mean if you're going to
say that someone that's involved with
organized crime and conducts you know is
involved in criminal activity is the
same as all Jewish people wouldn't that
be more anti-semitic you're saying all
Jewish people do that kind of stuff I
mean you know I think it's
complicated when you get to that level
of stuff and I think the ADL to a big
extent does that and if you look at
their funding historically you have
people like the bronfmans I think Wexner
is involved to an extent I I think he
works with some other groups though but
some of these other groups that do make
those allegations you talk about
powerful billionaires that may have been
involved in criminal activity and like
oh you're looking into that you're an
anti-semite I mean some of those groups
are funded by these billionaires yeah
and that's ultimately what I'm saying
and they're using it as protection for
themselves to the detriment of the
broader Jewish Community correct and you
look at someone like Leslie Wexner he's
a major funder of North American Jewish
leadership right but he's a guy
allegedly tied to organized crime and
he's made very controversial comments
about his spiritual persuasion right and
so this is a guy that has been directing
you know Jewish American religious life
for a very long time
and also very influential with Israeli
government people through the Wexner
Israel fellows program since the late
1980s
you know and the Brahman family is of
course they run a program called Israel
right yeah a major major yeah yeah that
actually came out of of this Mega group
that was created by Leslie Wexner and I
believe Charles Bronson in 1991 and it
was steinhardt and bronfman that got
together and created Birthright Israel
and Michael steinhardt is someone who's
uh he's very open about being an atheist
and thinks that Jewish people said
replace their faith with
um you know basically worship of the
state of Israel and stuff so you know
it's very complicated so you know
um once you get into that kind of money
and power and stuff it does become
complicated and I think we should be
able to talk about that stuff because if
we can't
that's not good right people need to be
held accountable if they're involved in
in organized crime and any stuff it
doesn't matter what ethnic group you
were part of or what religious group
you're a part of you know we're all
equal right or at least we're supposed
to be so you should be equally
accountable well respect you for doing
what you're doing because what you're
doing requires a lot of risk and you've
openly talked about being a mother I'm
glad last night you got eight hours of
sleep
yeah not quite I have a 10 month old
so your Today's Energy by Whitney is
sponsored by coffee yeah two cups of
coffee today but but to wrap it up here
for yourself
your your profession you could write
about a lot of different things that's
not as risky as this you're writing
about something a topic that's very very
risky
uh how's your husband feel about you
doing this does he sit there and say
babe we got two kids what are you doing
she and I do the same stuff he's in the
same business as well so he's all
forward he's like you guys are True
Believers and this is what you're
committing to for the restroom we have
to fight for a better world yeah yeah we
have to fight for a better world for our
kids what concerns you long term
oh man I mean there's a lot of stuff
right now that really freaks me out I
guess I would say especially in the US
this war on domestic Terror stuff is
very concerning when you have the
president of the United States giving a
major speech and basically labeling a
large segment of the country potential
domestic terrorists just because they
support a different political candidate
and that's coming from a person that
doesn't like Trump you're not a trump oh
no no no but I think you know
uh there's I have a lot of concerns yeah
about the direction this country is
going but really you know a lot of the
world is in a very complicated position
right now
and you know the question is
um you know who are making the supposed
solutions to this problem a lot of you
know the big issues of today right we're
being told oh they're so urgent we have
to solve them immediately here's the
solutions let's Implement them but a lot
of people aren't looking at what the
solutions are who made them if they're
really going to benefit us all it's all
about you know urgency but really the
domestic Terror stuff it concerns me
because they're basically
um some of the policy papers for that
from the bite Administration sort of
conflate uh things that go against the
government narrative as National
Security threats
and what happens if that ends up going
to its logical conclusion
you know and they say stuff like you say
stuff online that makes people disagree
with each other that's a national
security threat okay so we all have to
agree everyone in the U.S has to agree
about
with the government narrative
or you're a national security threat or
what you're saying is a national
security threat and you can't be allowed
online you can't be part of the public
discourse you know democracy requires
that we have all sides heard and the
more you start stifling not just like
one side but just anyone that doesn't
agree with the government we are going
to get to a dark place very quickly
and that worries me what happens once
that takes place you know I live in
Chile and South America there was a
government like that in Chile not that
long ago people still remember it and
it's not pretty it's never happened
early in the US before I don't think
people really realize what all that
involves
what was the situation in Chile like uh
there was a U.S sponsored coup d'etat in
1973 that and saw installed Pinochet he
was a military dictator and uh basically
you know mass murder Mass disappearing
of dissidents that was enabled actually
but I see it the CIA of something called
Operation Condor our government our
intelligence apparatus a lot of the
people I write in the book designed
domestic dissidents uh disappearing you
know programs and protocols that were
used by Foreign governments what happens
if someday they decide to turn that
stuff on us domestically what do you
think the war on domestic terror is it's
designed by these same people Iran
Contra Oliver North uh he created
something called main core which was a
database of U.S domestic dissidents that
were going to be rounded up in the event
of a vaguely defined National Emergency
they've tried this before will they get
away with it are they trying to do that
now uh this domestic Terror stuff if you
follow it to its roots you look at that
stuff going on with the 80s Iran Contra
the aftermath of Oklahoma City stuff
that was going on after 9 11. there is a
faction in our government that likes
that type of government that they've
installed in places like Chile and other
places around the world and I think
there is a fight in our National
Security State apparatus uh between that
faction and other people and that that
faction wants to bring that style of
government here to the United States is
this what the Trump refers to as the
Deep State well yeah I guess so but I
think Trump in order to be in power has
made some sort of alliance with the Deep
state to an extent I mean in in the
sense that he was able to sort of uh you
know not be jfkade right but I think at
the same time uh made an alliance with
deep State not necessarily maybe some
factions of it to get I mean in order to
be a Presidential nominee of one of the
two parties you have to make again
unsavory alliances but I don't think
it's again I don't think the Deep
State's a monolith right I don't think
it's one group one guy that I'll agree
with each other you're going to have
different factions in there it's kind of
hard to believe because most of them
hate this guy no a lot of them hate most
of them I would say hate this guy the
Russia gate stuff all those guys yeah
sure I think we can call that the Deep
state but again this is not a monolithic
group
um you're talking about people that all
they care about really is expanding
their money in power and sometimes
they're going to butt heads with each
other sometimes they're gonna come
together sometimes they're going to be
at each other's throats
um it's it evolves a lot you know when
it comes to talking about what exactly
happened during Trump's first term I
mean it's very complicated but the
extreme resistance he got from you know
mainstream Media or you know even the
intelligence service and all that stuff
I mean there was a lot of really crazy
stuff going on right remember that one
interview that he did where he's like uh
when they basically said uh they were
talking about Putin and MBS and Saudi
Arabia and he said uh well you think the
US is that innocent
right calling out that's hard to say in
U.S politics today you know it's really
hard to be a big time politician in this
country unless you perpetuate sort of a
fairy tale narrative about what the US
government is and has done and the
reality is it's anything but that yeah
totally yeah I mean listen it's by the
way has anybody here threatened you your
life or not yet you're safe you haven't
had any weird emails I mean everyone I
think gets weird emails you mean because
it's the internet whether they're people
that are threatening you or just saying
all sorts of crazy stuff I mean whatever
uh but I'm not really worried about it
because you know I think a lot of what
we're seeing right now is on on one
level sort of a spiritual or energetic
battle in a sense you know and I think
that if you are afraid you're giving
these power these people power over you
if you're afraid of them so I think
you're you know your commitment to
what's good about humanity and what
you're fighting for uh what we enjoy in
life you know our our future our
children all that stuff your commitment
to that has to be total when is your
what month's your birthday uh October
October what 17th okay that makes sense
you guys are one day apart
by the way just for the record Public
Service Announcement I think it's fair
to say Whitney Patrick and I we have
zero plans of suicide this is not
anything we're thinking of we got to
give that disclaimer out there well
people are afraid about that and I think
that's why more people don't come
forward but I think in today's world you
know it's much cheaper for them to just
call me a conspiracy theorist and smear
me than to hire someone to like take me
out you know what I mean yeah that makes
sense okay so uh once again appreciate
you for coming out this was fantastic I
think we need another couple hours oh
yeah uh audience if you're listening to
this if you were fascinated by this
you're in the middle of it my suggestion
share the hell out of this video with
others and just ask them what do you
think about what uh Whitney has to say
and then we're gonna put the link below
to both books to order both books volume
one and volume two uh Tyler if he can
put it in the chat as well as at the top
of the comment section and let's pin it
to the top so people can go order her
book and we'll in the description so I
will put the website that he can come
and find you as well go ahead sure no if
I could just say so you know two volumes
I should probably explain the difference
between them volume two is the bulk of
the Epstein Leslie white snorkeling
Maxwell material but if you're not
familiar with some of the things we
talked about today BCCI Iran Contra you
want to know more about the history of
Roy Cohn Robert Keith Gray Bill Casey
some of these guys that came up uh
you'll need to read volume one to
understand the big picture
um I mean you can read volume two and
get a lot of the stuff about Epstein out
of it but if you want to know the
broader history and how long this has
been this has been going on in our
country I would recommend you read
volume one but volume one is a lot
denser and it's a lot more uh you know
it's kind of work to read because it's a
dance because a lot of things start with
two you're almost saying Stars no well I
would personally start with one if you
wanted because a lot of people like to
go chronological but some people you
know got volume one were like where's
Epstein you know so I just wanted to let
you know that's a good disclaimer folks
if you enjoy us having more guests like
this and this the first time you you're
coming on this podcast because someone
shared it with you and you support us
asking these questions having these
types of guests please subscribe to the
channel and click on the alert button
having said that thank you so much for
coming out we may have a surprise
podcast coming soon stay with us we'll
let you know if it does happen take care
everybody bye-bye bye bye